[Musique]
je sais de quel plaisir on m'a conçu je
connais du bonheur
un aperçu j'aime l'odeur des draps après
la nuit la laine du goudron après la
plume
j'ai traversé les chats j'ai répété 60
vols en france
mme ottan d'été mais qui je voudrais
scène
quelle
autre
rhj loisirs de naître
[Musique]
j'en sais rien
si x 10 ans déjà ce n'est pas rien
soixante balais dépôt mallet
qui je voudrais être
j'en sais rien
j'aime nos rendez-vous de croisement
res nous embarrasse
l'impôt
nos doigts nous même chambre les poncifs
humour noir de notre choix
[Musique]
j'aime croire qu'on ne mourra jamais je
tente dire oui mieux que oui mais
qui je voudrais c'est
ok venez
[Musique]
choisir de naître
j'en sais rien
s'il faut dix ans déjà c'est même pas
rien soixante balais de pau balen crap
naquit je voudrais amiens
je pense à
vous
mais
j'aime notre mélange notre vacarme la
salive de l'eau le sel
qui je voudrais
non
je n'ai
eux
choisirent de n'être
rien
[Musique]
su faire dix ans déjà ce n'est pas rien
son ballet de pop allègre qui je
voudrais être
j'en sais rien
[Musique]
moi qui je voudrais être
je n'en sais rien
[Musique]
manas
[Applaudissements]